bonsoir nicolas vidal merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on nous a
appris apa faire confiance aux sondages
mais tout de même ils se suivent parfois
se ressemblent ce nouveau sondage pour
la présidentielle d'année une nouvelle
fois mené le maquereau quasiment égalité
avec marine le pen dans le duo tête
inexorablement comment peut-on l'analyse
est même ressorti la nuit vous avez
entièrement raison c'est finalement ce
sondage c'est toujours bien vous l'avez
dit se ressemblent ils se suivent et se
ressemblent et en fait si l'affrontement
rêver un pour le système en place avec
la certitude de voir emmanuel macron
rester au pouvoir 1 avril 2022 mais
finalement moins la question qui me pose
ce soir rappelez-vous législatives
s'étaient pratiquement 60% restants sur
les municipales avant pareil finalement
moi je vois ça comme un théâtre d ombres
qui permet de ne plus réfléchir à la
démocratie dans ce pays et forcément est
forcément vous le savez ça alimentant la
palabre politique et y moi c'est quelque
chose qui cache un peu la réalité de ce
pays cette fracture démocratique de fond
donc des sondages c'est bien mais vous
savez depuis dix ans depuis 20 ans
aujourd'hui les français sont devenus
des sondages descendez des pourcentages
et pour certains des segments mais
toujours pas de réflexion toujours pas
de big bang sur l'abstention 60% des
français n'ont pas voté aux législatives
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est son
job que peu d'intérêt parce que si on
commencerait d'un détail des forces
politiques en présence on boit quand
même qui a une certaine je vais le dire
je vais dire un gros mot une certaine
homogénéité
selon moi c'était une grue nicolas vidal
il ya aussi les sondages et les
personnalités testées celles qui ne sont
pas loin de moi l'idée de dire qui est
une manipulation mais il peut y avoir
effectivement une forme de suggestions
dans les sondages et peut-être peu de
créativité finalement bien entendu bien
entendu une suggestion de marine le pen
emmanuel macron vous imaginez bien qu
emmanuel macron il a envie d'avoir
marine le pen aujourd'hui enfin
aujourd'hui on a vu le 1022 dans
quelques mois face à lui ce sera
beaucoup plus simple est émis par contre
moi je suis pas convaincu que ça sera le
résultat final je ne suis pas convaincu
comme d'avec 2022 nous aurons peut-être
emmanuel macron et marine le pen face à
face ce duo qui arrange bien tout le
monde quand je parle de tout le monde
soyons clairs je pars de la classe
politique dans son ensemble donc oui on
nous fait le jeu du duo mâcon le pen
marine le pen et ses cannes
considérablement mais considérablement
pasteurisé depuis quelques mois elle a
épousé il faut le dire elle a épousé les
idées du système et d'ailleurs ça fait
penser à quelque chose ça me pensez vous
savez à matteo salvini en italie qui lui
aussi finalement a épousé l'idée du
système dangereusement et puis une
nouvelle fois marine le pen et je crois
que ça va être le l'enjeu de cette
présidentielle c'est finalement elle ne
veut plus de sortir l'union européenne
elle veut plus sortie de l'euro est elle
finalement elle a épousé aussi la cdh à
la communauté voilà c'est de la chance
ça c'est extrêmement important parce que
marine le pen est en train de reculer
partout parce que moi je pense marine le
pen elle est terrorisée par les sondages
et elle elle aussi elle est le nez dans
les sondages très très régulièrement et
je pense que tout ça non que de
conviction il ça me fait penser un peu
voyez-vous a finalement à des
convictions format de tuyaux d'arrosage
ils savent je crois que dans la
situation notre pays aujourd'hui ça va
être très très compliqué et ça va être
extrêmement intéressant de voir qui va
être face à face à neuville 2022
stéphanie cdh a comme comment cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et du
côté un nicolas vidal de l'opposition
les républicains et les socialistes
malgré la multiplication des
candidatures sont eux plutôt en tout cas
alors on en mauvaise posture
ben oui parce que ça renvoie une
fracture crucial qui exigent depuis au
moins 20 ans c'est entre les
progressistes emmanuel macron année le
choix entre le parangon et les
souverainistes et finalement les
républicains qu'est ce qui se passe chez
républicain déjà il ya tellement de
candidats qui sont presque plus nombreux
que les cadres chez l air donc ça ça va
être une question je suis assez amusé un
même dévasté parfois devant le nombre de
candidatures qui a mais la réalité c'est
que les républicains ils sont macron
compatible je l'avais déjà dit d'un
édito finalement ce sont des
mondialistes qui ne s'assume pas ils
sont européistes à mort il parle de
souveraineté nationale de soins
qu'européennes pardon là d'ssus comme
bien des vertes ans donc en fait ils ne
peuvent pas se distancer des manuels
macron il salue la politique c'est
souvent des couloirs présidentielle le
problème c'est que sans ce même couloir
et emmanuel macron est très très loin
devant et ils suivent en fait que ça
soit very pécresse xavier bertrand
michel barnier qui est ancien
commissaire européen vous voyez
finalement cap à l'espace de papier à
cigarette entre tous ils ont pas ils ont
rien à faire valoir les républicains
aujourd'hui et ça c'est un vrai problème
et d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils se sont
pas ils sont tenus de commenter la
proportion aux élections initiative ne
serait ce qu'au broussailles et bertrand
il faut rappeler xavier bertrand s'est
17% des inscrits 10 7% les esprits donc
c'est quand même un 6e minable est-ce
que la possible candidature d'eric
zemmour pourrait-il rebattre les cartes
ben oui parce qu'eric zemmour il fait la
conjonction en fait vous savez entre la
souveraineté et l identité vous saviez
7e ce qu'avait fait nicolas sarkozy
quand il était conseillé par patrick
buisson son conseiller il n'avait pas
adopté la ligne buisson et c'est
peut-être aussi pour ça qui a perdu
dernière fois mais finalement eric
zemmour il fait cette objection entre
souveraineté identité ça qu'on partage
ou pas des 10es mots il faut quand même
reconnaître qu'il éclaire sur tous les
sujets régaliens et sahil il incarne
aussi un espoir pour beaucoup de
français il rebat les cartes et
rappelez-vous dès le début du mouvement
de gilles est jeune on parlait souvent
mais moi peut-être d'un candidat qui
sortirait du lot qui sortirait du sérail
et peut-être et peut-être qu'eric
zemmour et va être ce candidat là on
voit qu'il est déjà en précampagne on le
voit il a fait la promo de son bouquin
dans quelques jours le 17 septembre je
crois donc finalement il va faire une
campagne sous couvert de promotion
littéraire mais eric zemmour il est
vraiment dans cette idée là et et je
crois qu'il pourrait vraiment vraiment
bousculés l'échéance de la
présidentielle après on verra c'est
encore long il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui vont se passer beaucoup de
mouvements sociaux vous le savez par
emmanuel macron mais vraiment eric
zemmour je pense que c'est très
intéressant et dernière idée ce qui
était vrai pour marine le pen avant 2017
ils sont désastreux débat d'entre deux
tours eric zemmour aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il peut jouer comme une soupape de
sécurité pour une france plus
conservatrices plus traditionnelles qui
pourrait attendre sagement que eric
zemmour se présente donc effectivement
je pense qu'il a pris la place de marine
le pen dans cette soupape de sécurité
populaire et démocratique dont un peu
mon analyse sur eric zemmour aujourd'hui
merci en tout cas avoue nicolas vidal je
rappelle que vous êtes un éditorialiste
merci à vous